last time on The Walking Dead chef Brian
and I battled it out to see who can make
the best Bloody Sunday now a random
stranger will decide my fate on the show
and the future of my self-published
cookbook here comes a random stranger
walking up now whoa Ozzy Osbourne there
really is random want to try nice piece
sure why not
[Music]
okay now try mine
[Music]
well this is no business of ours Oh easy
I see chefs Brian's best what sorry
Gordon looks like you're off the show
no hard feelings put her there Gordon
chose me
just like you say just like we planned
attack according you business Tom be
outbreak gonna go to the fridge hurt
Dave in the fridge I took care of that
Gordon you really did it this time but
did you have to drag chef Ryan into this
don't tell my wife and kids I love them
my dog blondi you won't be telling
anyone anything
what are you talking about remember that
fish your head last night with your
girlfriend that's a little recipe I
called radioactive Hakata Suzie's world
is definitely not responsible if you
died for me
because I guarantee you well you can
only push me and push me so far before I
snap warning gruesome prepare to meet
your final course
[Music]
you're the walk
[Music]
welcome to the season finale of The
Walking Dead this one comes from a user
named legitimate lemonade he or she
writes if you had Dave so much why
haven't you eat him well stupid lemonade
name has nothing to do with Dave's hat
but I still have a perfect human recipe
to demonstrate it'll be great for all
grilling occasions including zombie
Independence Day kill all humans Day and
Labor Day for this recipe you'll need
salt pepper onion powder garlic powder
that human Brown corner and red pepper
flakes while we wait for Dave to pass
I'm gonna demonstrate with ground beef
corn and ribs in place of the dead human
I knew I should have added a pinch of
cyanide to his fish start by adding
seasoning to everything for the beef
you'll want to form it into a skull
shape get it in there nice and tight I
bought this for $5 online because it
looks like me but anyways you packed the
beef in there and it makes it taste and
feel like a real human plate
[Music]
what is that nobody opened the door
anyways we need to wrap the cord in
tinfoil good night little buddy I'll
sing you a lot of I'll able to carry all
this stuff you'll need a tray but I like
to use Oh walk whoa Dave no need to pull
the race card FTA [ __ ] put your
goddamn hands where I can see you what
is this
I got reports you eating baby brains
radioactive foods and a whole lot of
other [ __ ] you dead [ __ ] are you Corden
gruesome
no that's corny gruesome boys bucum
please gruesome I got this shot all
lined up so don't try anything you I
gots it fresh
welcome to the show buddy you know book
item 80 always a forever man all right
Chris your job for the next two human
hours with jacquard this grill with your
life because that's how long it takes to
cook these ribs at 375 degrees fair
of 160 degrees Fahrenheit in the court
in cook for 20 minutes you can rotate it
slowly if you're not a shot
[Applause]
[Music]
and steadily really Forks are a tool
friend Ally humans well this brings us
again
we've cooked up six of the most
delicious recipes known to man and
somehow Dave and I didn't kill each
other anyways much fun as I did like it
subscribe and do this in your own
kitchen your own grill in your own
or chef according to see
[Music]
coming up on the 10 o'clock news the new
phenomenon that all the kids are calling
road head but first the story of how the
FDA opened fire on celebrity chef Gordon
gruesome sources say that he was filming
an episode of his show the walking dead
when the incident occurred hundreds are
presumed dead Gruesomes whereabouts are
still unknown
we are the walk
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]